[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell we are here for you this
hour
what do you need to talk about it is a
free phone call the phone number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
george will help you on those really
specific tough money questions i'll
chime in as well but how about your work
how about the shovel
how about the fact that
through your income
through work in the hottest job economy
we've ever seen george you can increase
the size of the shovel and get out of
debt get that emergency fund funded
catch up on that retirement and keep on
going pay for college the whole nine
yards it all works together so if you're
feeling stuck i can promise you you're
not let's help you figure that out in
your job stuff because george the work
and the money so the relationships and
work relationships and money
they're all inextricably connected if
you're off in one of those three areas
it's affecting all three and that's why
we do the ramsay show yeah and when you
get some help in one it really helps the
other in so many ways it absolutely does
so uh maybe later in the show we'll see
if time allows george has got a new
french bulldog i haven't talked to him
since we may dig into that that's what
america needs to hear you get debt free
and pay off your house and what do you
do i don't see you on a cruise no i i i
see you with a new french bulldog you
know a cruise lasts a week ken the
french bulldog hopefully 10 12 years for
lucky
that's how i see it it's a good roi oh i
love it all right let's get to zach in
charlotte north carolina zach how can we
help
hey guys what's going on well we are
living the dream what are you doing
well i'm i'm doing the same i'm blessed
thanks for taking my call i got a little
bit of a two-part question for you i
could probably ask you a million but
trying to be specific so okay
i'm planning a and i've been planning
the career change for the past year um i
had the opportunity to move
and
take this change last may and um some
financial i wasn't where i was in the
middle of baby step two
some other things going on my personal
life i just said hey let's slow down
let's pause
reevaluate
and uh here we are um six seven months
later and
i'm certain this is what i want to do
where i want to be and so
i'm looking at where i'm at my baby
steps i'm
on pace to be done with baby step two by
the middle of
june last july all right um
i'm getting ready to be completely
consumer debt free and the only thing i
the last part of that is a
11 000 student loan
um that i have okay
and i know from listening you know when
you're you're making a big life change
i'm gonna create making a career change
press pause that cash
um
so i've sort of balled it out that i
think i can have between 13 if i press
pause
in march
and i'll be completely out of everything
except that student loan
um
if i if i stack up cash and i keep
following baby steps like i have been
instead of just throwing it on dead
saving it
i think i'll have between 13 and 16 k to
make this move slash career change all
right so let's um so let's figure out
what is this move career change and and
why do you need 13 to 16 000 to make it
well yeah so
the easy part is i'm i'm transitioning
from the steadiness of public education
to real estate
selling selling commercial or
residential
residential okay
okay so yeah and
condition also i'm moving from a small
town to a big city
and i know it's going to be a quite a
change and quite the uh financial change
as well okay so i just want to make sure
i'm also prepared for this news okay
so
is this a money question i know it's a
money question but are you asking me
something because here's the here's what
i see
real estate is going to be there
a year from now two years from now three
years from now i i i guess i'm not
hearing enough evidence george and i are
going to tackle this with you but george
i don't hear anything in here that says
he needs us to pause paying off the debt
when we are as we sit here today we're
talking about five five and a half
months
you've got it all paid off and then we
move into baby step three yeah am i
right
well the flip side is that i'm a school
teacher and so the part of that question
on the equation left out is
last may when i decided to come back i
said hey i'm going to commit to one more
year at my school
and this coming summer you know when
i'll make the transition oh and so i i i
i made a year-long commitment and i'm
not in a place where i want to make
another year long commitment
to return to that same school district
okay so my question is so your salary
it's by a contract so you're not going
to have salary extending through the
summer
correct i'll get a couple extra
paychecks one in july one in august okay
and um okay but hold on i have silent
work
right so here's my deal i don't think
you pause
pause anything pay off the debt because
that's going to take more pressure off
of you when you finally move to
charlotte north carolina and then go all
in as a realtor i'll hand it to george
in a second but let me tell you what i
know about
uh real estate uh because i'm really
good friends with byron buffini he's
been a guest on this show he's he's kind
of the dave ramsey of the real estate
training world and and he's told me
unequivocally to really win in real
estate you have to go all in
so while i do understand what you're
saying you want to pile up some cash
uh to be able to kind of buffer that
first 90 days of getting your first
house and selling it that i understand
but george i hand it to you because i
believe uh that he needs to do that but
he only does that after he pays off the
debt the real estate's going to be there
so if he's got to have two or three side
hustles
i want the debt paid off before he goes
full time into real estate yeah i'm
amending everything ken said it feels
like you're kicking the can down the
road but the better thing to do is get
rid of the can so you can focus on real
estate without any debt will if with a
fully funded emergency fund so that
you're not worried about this there's no
reason you need sixteen thousand dollars
to get started in real estate do you
have your real estate license already
yes yeah you did you just finished
actually yeah awesome have you been i'm
traveling i mean i'm not i'm
like talking to some guys that i'm as as
far as actually selling though i'm not
in the city i'm moving to i'm about two
hours away so sure i'm i'm focused on my
three or four side gigs plus my teaching
job now plus trying to learn and mentor
but i'm not actually selling perfect um
but here's the deal
george is absolutely right get rid of
the can
because then then okay based off your
and i'm so glad you called i want to
encourage you your head's you're
thinking through the right stuff you're
just not thinking about the right way if
we remove the debt we get all the debt
out that's less money that you have to
kind of have in savings as you get
yourself on your feet here this would be
my exact move i'd pay off the debt do
everything you're doing now i would pay
it off june you come out of this thing
debt paid off
if you've already made the move great if
you haven't made the move then you make
the move we go get solid and stable in
this new city where you're going to be a
full-time real estate agent okay if you
got to work three or four side hustles
there for a while until you kind of get
the apartment or rent all that figured
out fine but then you're all in yeah i
would be getting you
so you would say using because i mean by
say let's say
july 15th i could be debt free and
have three or four more thousand dollars
coming in over the course of the summer
go ahead and make the move then with
that money coming in yes i'm excited
just thinking about that plan yeah and
you can go tutor work those side hustles
i would love for you to be debt free
with an emergency fund by the time you
jump into this new career and remember
even though i'm saying yes if it turns
out it needs to be september october for
that move that's fine too we want to
make this new move just at a nice pace
no need to be frenetic because your best
income days are easily
not too far in the distant future thank
you so much for the call zach he's
george campbell i'm ken coleman don't
move more ramsay show coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell we're here for you this hour
triple eigh eight two five five two two
five you got money questions
relationship questions work questions
that are all
intertwined and george and i are here to
help you out today triple eight eight
two five five two two five uh let's go
to randy who's in san luis obispo
california uh randy how can we help
hey how you guys doing we are having a
blast randy what's up
so i uh just have a quick question i'm
familiar with like the baby steps
program
got the baby step one done um
right now it's like a really good time
to sell a car like i guess the car
market's really low so
i'm in debt like 18 000 on my car
and
car payments are about 500 a month
then i also have like 10 000 in credit
card debt
and so i'm trying to figure out if it's
worth it to sell the car
pay off that debt and then maybe get
like a
i don't want to say a beater car but
something that's just not as aggressive
in payments or
even something that i could just pay off
like
for 2 000 or something i just kind of
need some advice if it's worth it should
i
get out of that card loan
and i mean it's an opportunity to have
500 extra months to pay off the 10 000
in debt you're on you're on the right
track randy what's the car worth you
said you have 18k in debt what is it
worth
i got a blue book for cash for 20 000.
boom nice that is what i like to hear
so originally when i first got the car i
put 6 000 of an already existing loan
into that loan so i feel like i'm like
kind of making out
so what's your household income
um i'm at like per year per month per
year
uh like 68 000. awesome
okay so if you sell this car for 20k
you get rid of the loan and you have 2k
left
right
yeah so then obviously right there
there's an opportunity to buy another
car well first the opportunity is to pay
off your credit card debt
well yeah exactly and then with the
money left over
we're going to buy a reliable used car
and it doesn't have to be a beater but
we're not we're not going to spend 15
grand on a used car and we're never
going to go into payments again you said
well maybe something with less
aggressive payments zero is a much less
aggressive payment would you agree
right yeah i would completely agree yes
so go buy you a five six thousand dollar
honda or toyota that'll last you a long
time and that will then free up your
income you'll have no payments after
that right
yeah oh that feels kind of where my
head's out i just i i just know that
that's going to be so i brought it up to
my boss he's kind of like a mentor and
he said i know your head's at but it's a
nice car i wouldn't do it and i'm kind
of like damn it i shouldn't have asked
him because now i'm in like a
you know ask asking someone who i really
respect a lot you know you know what
happens when broke people drive nice
cars they stay broke
it's so true and it's sad you make great
money you're a hard-working guy and
you're bringing the first impression
yeah it's true yeah but you know here's
the deal struggling randy don't do don't
beat up on yourself but it's the
equivalent of me asking a technology
question to the trainer at the gym he
might have an opinion i might respect
him because of his muscles and his
workout habits but is he really a
technology expert
he called george george is a money
expert and i have no muscles well that's
true too
both can be true at the same time listen
don't beat yourself up over it just
because you respect him and he had a
different opinion what do you know to be
right having heard what george tell you
what do you believe to be right what
should you do
i i honestly i feel like if i can get
what especially with putting the
negative six grand from the prior loan
into this
car and then being able to sell for two
grand more i feel like it's
practically getting the lottery ticket
you know all right you're undoing some
stupid tax which i like yeah do it today
don't think about it don't ask anybody
else just do it
move forward so i'm talking about major
progress here let's go to cameron next
in tampa florida cameron how can we help
cloudy uh so
i'm basically just gonna explain my
situation and hopefully y'all can either
knock me outside the head or you know
say you're doing good and here's
somebody are we that aggressive ken well
he wants us to be sure okay you tell us
what you want it's his show his call
so currently i'm in the
market for looking for a home and
basically the criteria that i have for a
home is
i don't know if you'll probably know the
term house hacking but essentially
you're going to live in one room rent
out the additional rooms and it should
be enough to cover the mortgage on the
house um so i'm looking for a three
bedroom two bath and um the market is
extremely aggressive um most people are
playing far above list i've already put
in offers with you know ten thousand
above list with the weight waves
appraisal agencies of course they still
fit the criteria that i listed out
before
um but i is this a good plan is this
something i should pursue further
because basically the only way that i'm
going to get a house at this point is to
go way above over what the appraisal's
going to be and then have just extra
money that's going to be given towards
the loan um
you know kind of that i won't be able to
get a mortgage for
so i guess basically my question goes
out is how far should i extend myself
out i am you know i am debt free and i
do have plenty of money saved up for the
house but uh you know is is this how
much how much do you have saved
so right now it's about 32 000 and
that's just specifically set aside for
buying a house and how much are these
houses you're looking at
my price range is anywhere from about
200 to 250.
okay
so this house hacking idea i i do know
about it and it's done by a lot of the
the real estate investing gurus on tick
tock and they're all you know pushing it
and i love that you're debt-free it
makes me wary already it does and i'm a
fan of you buying the house that you can
afford regardless of who may or may not
rent and who may or may not give you the
money that you want yeah can i jump in
george before you give more financial
advice i just gotta know
why
are you married single like well i need
to understand like what's the purpose of
buying something that you then turn
around and rent two of the three
bedrooms to somebody else is this
straight like investment play for you
and you're trying to is that the deal so
that you relationally this isn't
affecting your life
no so currently um i graduated last year
from texas and then moved to tampa for
work um i'm currently renting out an
apartment it's fairly expensive and as
i'm looking at real estate prices
what rents are going for you know it's
only going up and up and up the longer i
hold on to money the more it's going to
be in a way by inflation it's a
basically real estate's a pretty safe
place to keep money and so it's going to
be basically you know tackling the
purpose of i have a place to put my
money that's safe and i'll be able to
you know live for free essentially is
kind of the hope
there's no such thing as no such thing
as free my man i'm sorry yeah i wish
there's your first myth you've been
watching tick tock or
these motivational morons that are
standing by jets and taking pictures and
duping people like you and they're
freaking you out and scaring you that
keeping your money safe is somehow
stupid inflation isn't going to continue
at the crazy rate it is now it's just
not
so cameron let me give you some
parameters that will help because you
have your own set i'll tell you what i
would do if i was in your shoes i would
save up 10 to 20 down you have you have
that but i would do it on a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage
and i want that payment to be no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
regardless of whoever rents look at that
as gravy on top and if you can afford a
place like that that's less than 25
percent of your take-home pay on the
15-year fix you've got 10 to 20 down
ideally 20 or more to avoid that pmi
then i would say hey this is a great
idea man
which may mean you need to wait a few
more months save up a little more and
right now the market is crazy and you're
putting 10 20 over asking do not waive
inspections do not wave appraisals
that's how you get into a mess and it
becomes it goes from free to very
expensive because you didn't look into
all the issues so don't rush into this
you're a young guy you're sharp you're
doing great but this may mean this is a
three-year journey for you instead of a
tomorrow thing
not what you wanted to hear i'm sure
well i mean
you're right then it's something that i
was prepared for you know that's kind of
why i came on the call it's just like i
said to get knocked inside the head if
it was necessary well we're really not
knocking you upside down because here's
the deal you're a really sharp guy and
you're debt free and you're young and
you've got enormous financial potential
i i think what i'm hearing cameron is
that
you're hearing some influences
that make you feel like if you don't
move this money and get it into real
estate now you're really blowing it and
that's simply not the case george did a
wonderful job of laying out what the
risks are and what the myths are so hang
tight keep building keep hustling man
get more money and do it in a way that's
stable and do it in a way that makes the
most sense you're fine
stay the course i don't like mixing
investment property with my primary
residence yeah it's got its place but
right now you've got to focus on you man
you'll do fine in life they already are
doing incredible thank you so much for
the call hey don't move more of the
ramsey show right after this
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right folks welcome back to the
ramsey show where we help you win
financially we're gonna help you win
professionally we're gonna help you win
relationally all those
major areas of your life have got to be
on purpose you got to be moving forward
to live that life that you want to live
uh and uh we just talked about
relationships george
married folks got to talk to you i want
you to just imagine for a moment never
having another money argument with your
spouse
you done imagining i mean that's pretty
amazing how much better would your
marriage be
when you get on the same page with your
money you're gonna have more peace in
your finances and your marriage and the
best way to do this is to join a
financial peace university class you're
going to learn how to make a budget
together
follow our proven money plan so you can
stop fighting about money and start
chasing your goals as a team
millions of couples have gone through
the class and say it's the best thing
they could have done for their marriage
and it can be for your marriage as well
decide today that you're ready to get on
the same page with your spouse about
money to join an fbu class and get
started for free
visit
ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's
com
ramseysolutions.com
fpu all right back to the phones we go
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five marissa joins us in
appleton wisconsin marissa how can we
help
hi thanks for having me on first of all
um
so i just have a quick question for you
right now i'm on baby step number two um
i am 115k um in student loan debt um and
i have an offer right now on the table
to take a job at the church that i go to
um
in a
really cool position that really aligns
like morally what i believe in um more
than where i'm at right now but it is
eleven thousand dollar pay cut
um so i'm just kind of looking for some
guidance on if i should take that job or
if i should keep grinding out with my
current job until i'm debt free okay
i'm going to ask you a series of
questions and we'll dive in on this um
when do you expect if you were not to
have any interruption uh in your payment
plan uh to pay off the 115 000 student
loan debt
yeah so my husband and i um have a
really strict budget that we follow and
right now we're thinking a little less
than two years okay awesome boy you can
see it can't you
yeah yeah we started with um a hundred
and about eighty thousand dollars
so awesome yeah okay
um
next question
are you willing because this is a
relationship and you got a life outside
of work if you were to take and i'm not
recommending you take the church
position yet but if you were to take it
and so now we have an 11 000
difference all right spread out over the
12 months and you can i'm sure you guys
have already thought about what that
looks like in your budget
um are you willing to
make that 11 000 up
through a side hustle so that we don't
slow down at all so is that something
that even you can do relationally or
with everything else going on could you
do that yeah so i actually do have um
three other jobs on top of my current
job
um right now i make 51 000 but with my
other five jobs i'm around about 60.
um so i'm
i am side hustling right brought a lot
right now so i don't know if i could add
any extra on my plate may i be so bold
as to suggest that you can't add another
job four is enough
yeah all right so uh george jump in here
um i'm curious to know
i'm going to dive back in a second but
i'd like to i want to know we look at
that budget
okay
and i want to know uh marissa what is
the actual impact of the budget
towards debt elimination or just the
budget in general if we take that 11 000
gross pay cut
and we start you know working that out
what's the actual hit per month and
how's that slowing it down
yeah so i think
right now we're playing paying we live
pretty minimally on everything um we
rent
we really don't have a lot of luxuries
so all of our extra money is thrown at
bones
um so there's not a lot we can cut back
on like luxury items like you know hbo
max or something crazy like that because
we don't do any of that stuff so i think
the pay cut would
take a little bit of a hit on just like
the amount of debt we're paying each
month sure
um slow it down by how much
if for less than two years now how much
would it slow it down
yeah i would probably stay potentially
like
four to five hundred dollars a month
okay
because you're losing about a thousand
gross every month that yeah you know so
now we have a vote
okay
i'm curious uh talking about the budget
here do you guys get a refund from your
taxes every year
yeah we really need to adjust our taxes
we do get we do get um a large refund um
and we're going to talk to our
accountant about that but yeah we're
getting a decent refund yeah because
that's that's money that will make you
feel like you got a raise because you
did because that money was being hung on
to by the government uh interest-free so
let's fix that for sure and it sounds
like you guys are very focused on this
budget if i'm you i'm probably keeping
these side jobs maybe finding some that
are a little more lucrative so that if
you do switch this church position you
still have that extra 9 10 11 12 k
coming in if you want to make that jump
yeah let's that's a great point i'm glad
you made it what are you in the three
extra jobs
what are you what are you making per
hour in the three different jobs
yeah so um i made twenty dollars an hour
one of them one of them i make about 25
or 26 an hour and then one i only make
like twelve dollars an hour so that one
i definitely could probably how many
hours a week are you working on that one
um that one i'm only working um
like two to three times a month so it is
pretty okay it is limited yeah
it's not relieved all right
here's what i think is the uh the
ultimate question george on this one
i think it could be done
um i think it comes down to is this
church position that is open that's come
to you
is it
the right step
uh
into where you eventually want to be or
is it more of and there's nothing wrong
with either or on this but is it more i
love my church it's a really cool job i
would like it more than my regular day
job and i really would like to take it
is it strategic or is it just kind of
cool and kind of good
yeah i think i can kind of give you like
a little insight so i am i played um
soccer in college
and i'm one of my jobs as a soccer coach
so this position would be kind of like
starting a uh youth athlete program at a
church um and like starting from ground
zero so there's like no foundation
that's been laid yet
um
and so it in my ultimate dream is to
open up like my own training facility
for youth athletes um so this is very
strong
a little bit but
yeah a little bit i think where's your
husband on this what's his what's his
take
um yeah my husband is i mean i mean he's
supportive um but he just wants to make
sure that you know
i'm making the right decision he kind of
he is like a huge fan of you guys like
he actually is the one that kind of
showed me to you guys but um
he kind of said as long as this like
aligns where you want to be within five
to ten years he definitely supports
the decision but he wants to make sure
that it's something that
you know is going to put me in a place
that i want to be in well it's
definitely putting on your path i'm
still not i'm getting there i'm getting
there george i'm getting closer i want
to know what george thinks too but
i'm wondering if your husband could take
on a second job
yeah so my husband actually bartends um
on the weekends as well you guys are
amazing
yes yeah
all right so here's the deal yeah george
i want george to weigh in i'm gonna go
real quick all right sure i don't think
there's a right or wrong here i didn't
get a clear answer is it about a
six-month delay in paying off or
four-month delay if you were to take the
pay cut of the church did you decide
do you know um
six months about probably so here's the
deal uh george i if they can really do
it and it delays it six months and she
feels like it is the absolute best
opportunity to put her on the path she
wants to be on and she can't get it
anywhere else then i'd say i'd bite the
bullet and make the slight sacrifice but
if there's another way here's the
challenge if there's another way for her
to get on that path i'd say stick it out
don't take the pay cut find the other
way yeah my gut says if you can do this
and not slow down the baby steps i'm all
in and that might mean a lot of long
nights and long days but man you're
going to look back in your dream job
debt free in two years because you've
already been on this path for a while i
don't want to extend this thing out for
four years total so i want you to get
rid of this debt do whatever it takes
and have your dream job and i'm not
saying don't take it i'm just saying
this church job is not the only way to
get where you want to go so this needs
to be a good money decision because the
career thing it'll take care of itself
appreciate the call you're awesome
you're going to do some great great
things in the community through soccer
all right this is the ramsay show more
coming up don't you dare move
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show we're
helping you win in your life financially
relationally professionally i'm ken
coleman joined with my colleague
george campbell we're thrilled to be
with you the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five san antonio texas is where
we go next noah joins us there noah how
can we help
hi i had a question about life insurance
so i took out a policy uh via dave's
advice i was around
the
baby steps and the whole uh financial
piece to my parents all good stuff uh so
i took out life insurance for current
policy
uh
for the suggested amount and guidelines
all that stuff
but then i saw
all another life insurance policy or
against company that invests the money
that you make or the money that you uh
the money that you uh make as payments
you know obviously towards your uh your
insurance for life insurance so
uh instead of like instead of you not
getting anything out of it other than
life is dying you know your family's
protected but all that money that you
made in payment you know it's just you
know i you know quote down the drain
so
i wasn't wondering if i should just keep
the same
policy or if i could
switch over and have with this company
that invests the money that
that they'll make us payments over the
return
uh which brings you interest
got it now how old are you
24. 24. all right this is an age-old
trap that's been around for a long time
and what you are describing is whole
life insurance and if you've watched fpu
you know why we hate it with a burning
undying passion
and here's the reason you pay a lot more
money
and guess who makes that money
the guy who sold you the whole life
insurance and so that is why they sell
it they make very little from term life
because the premiums are so small
and here's the easiest way to explain it
your your insurance is insurance and
your investments are investments whole
life tries to do both
and really does neither of them very
well
and so when you say i want this money to
make money remember that's not the
purpose of insurance the purpose of
insurance is to protect you it costs you
money
and i want your investments to be
separate well you can do that that's
baby step four we're investing 15 of our
income to 401ks iras great investment
vehicles that can grow tax-free if
you've got the roth option so those are
what i would focus on if you want your
money to make money but leave your
insurance as insurance to protect you
okay yeah i was confused because it
advertised as term so i was like
i wasn't sure i was like that's not well
they've
turned will not do that
term insurance is not going to invest
for you so if they're labeling it as
that there's probably some fine print
there you got to look into it's probably
secretly a whole life policy that
they're labeling differently on purpose
so that you fall for it don't fall for
this man stick to the plan you've done
well
excellent let's go now to seattle
washington where alex joins us alex how
can we help
hi um thanks for having me on you bet
i'm calling because i recently sold i
bought a house last year which is my
primary residence and i sold the last
house i was living in and i ended up
with about a hundred thousand dollars
in cash
i have
the mortgage on the current house that i
live in
i have
two rentals and i have mortgages on the
rentals
um i make about 97 000 a year from my
job
and i make about 24 000 my cash flow
about 24 000 on the rentals
um
my expenses are three thousand dollars a
month
um and one of the questions the first
question that i have is should i
snowball
the rentals the mortgages on the rentals
as debt as they are
great question what's left on your
primary residence
400 000
okay and what's left on the rentals
uh 83
on my
lowest one and then 170 on the other one
okay so we've got a total of what like
213 on the rentals
yeah
so uh no
253 253 my bad so here's what i would do
if i was in your shoes i'm gonna pay off
my primary residence first and then i'm
going to attack the rentals with a
vengeance and yes you can attack them in
the debt snowball order there uh if you
want
that feels like it make you feel the
most progress
once you've got the paid off primary
residence but i want you to attack the
primary one first
okay i don't know that's the big one
right
that is the big one and i've been
feeling like just taking the money that
i have on savings and putting it on the
lowest one it just feels right so
i mean you could if you want to knock
out the first rental to free up that
payment that can then allow you to do
the others that's okay
but the reason is the safety i want you
to have in your primary residence you
know if the bank comes after you i want
you to be able to live in your house all
right
all right so i hear you george uh but
i'm also over here with alex i'm going
all right if he's got 100k in the bank
did you say one of the rentals was 83
you owed
yeah how much is that one worth if you
sold it
450 000.
georgie boy
that's big money all right now i'm gonna
just be willing to sell it i'm i don't
care if he's willing he needs to
because all of a sudden um you pay that
off
and then that allows you to to make a
huge chunk on your primary residence
that george is talking about that's huge
are you willing to do that are you
willing to pay off that lower rental
sell it and then take
all the profit from that and put it on
your primary residence
no i don't think so i think i would
rather snowball
that money because i want to leave my
job i don't like my job oh no hold on so
you just run out of ken coleman hold on
a second you've awoken him and i i but
are you does that mean when you leave
your job what does that mean you're just
gonna you're gonna live off of the the
the houses what what's the plan when we
leave the job we don't like
the rentals will provide
enough income for me once a house my
primary residence is paid off and those
rentals
are rented out providing the income so
that income is one thing and it'll allow
me to do
you know other kinds of work
how many years before you pay off
yeah but how many years is that
i'm talking about a long time um
if i pay off if i snowball what i have
right now i could pay off the first
rental right today i know i could pay
off the second rental in about 30 months
yeah um so under three years
and then looking at that money if i just
this is just snowballing this isn't sure
because he wasn't paying
much of other stuff i got kids colleges
and things but i could have
my primary residence paid off in eight
years yeah but you're going to stay in a
gym years after
yeah i know it's a long time to stay in
a job you hate
versus
might i just challenge you if you do
what i suggested
and pay off the first rental and sell it
and apply that
huge number to the whole snowball that
you just laid out you can leave that job
you don't like a whole lot faster and i
know you're minus one rental but that's
only about what 10 12 k
yeah that's not a game changer that's
not a game changer it's not enough for
you to thrive and survive on
i just think you need to think about
this being in a job you can't stand for
eight years to 10 years that's going to
have all kinds of effects on you
i don't think you can still
juice
well it's it provides all the there's no
job satisfaction it provides plenty of
money and it provides
but you can't live off 24 000 a year
which is what you told me the rentals
bring in
that's the cash flow
um so that would go up right but you
still have to work somewhere else here
here's the thing
you need to knock this debt out and you
can always get back into the rental
business and cash flow it you need to be
debt free it's going to give you so many
options but slugging it out in a job
that has no fulfillment for 8 to 10
years just because you want to hang on
to two rentals it's not going to take
care of you in the long term anyway
so i think you fast forward the dream i
think you get rid of the one rental sell
it apply the the 400 or whatever the you
know the profit is after all the real
estate and everything else put it on the
house
get out of debt fast forwards everything
man and then you can start buying
investment property with cash because
you don't have any debt exactly
love the plan i just wouldn't fast
forward it yeah hey i want to thank our
producer james chiles uh actually ben
hillson and our associate producer carl
screener kelly daniel george campbell
and you america thank you for joining us
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs a producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we help you live your best life by being
healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell we are here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's a
free call
and we're gonna meet you where you are
and give you a hope-filled plan of what
you need to do next to get where you
wanna be let's get it started in salt
lake city utah brett joins us there
brett how can we help
hey what's up guys um i'm 34 married
with five kids
i'm a high school auto shop teacher
and i have a pretty good thing going
i've been doing it for six years my wife
and i are getting on the same page
financially finally we've been paying
off a lot of debt
um and i have some retirement starting
it feels great yeah uh but my wife
has moved all around she look and she
lived in the south she wants to get back
to the south too many mormons in utah
she wants to get out oh i've lived here
my whole life yeah i've lived here my
i've lived here my whole life and so i'm
a little timid um we have we have a
mortgage and a heloc so the heloc is the
is the sore spot
um
and so and and uh the kicker is we have
five kids but we we don't have our
basement finished
so
she needs more room for the kids and she
says hey if you get a teaching job in
the south you could sell the house we
owe about 180 plus 53 on the heloc we
can sell the house for 550 560
and buy something cheaper in the south
so and have more space for the kids you
know trade our life here for a life
there sell the house i think your wife's
making a lot of sense
what's the hold up
what do you want george and i to say i
think your wife's got a really nice
picture
i know but i've got a good gig here i
get uh you know the the teacher job is
great love the kids i have my work
contributes 10
to my 401k and before i got this job i
had no savings i was terrible with money
so we've got 10 percent going to 401k
that's free money that's part of my
compensation it doesn't come out of my
salary household income i make 72 she
makes about 10 doing eyelash extensions
and coaching gymnastics
i'm just scared to leave my good thing
because i'm afraid and i've looked into
other states they're not going to have
as good of retirement and the pay won't
be quite as good
so you've looked at specific southern
locations that she's kind of said i'd be
willing to go here you looked at teacher
salaries she said texas to texas to
north carolina the traditional south
i've been looking and you know more
stuff's going to pop up
right and so and again just to clarify
uh you don't think you can't you haven't
found a location in any of those states
whatever the range is where you're
making 75 and you got a good 401k
no everything on on on indeed is showing
55 and then you have to pay into the
state retirement it's not it is you know
you can't get into a 401k contribute i
but i don't think this is a i think you
called
um
with a presenting kind of a money
slash
i'm right employment work question well
i think this is a relationship issue
before we get to the heloc okay
we're going to address the money and the
work stuff that's what you've presented
i think this is a relationship issue
how big of a deal is it to the wife
to get out of utah
i just need to know it may not be that
big of a deal how big of a deal is it
it's a major deal
georgia louisiana she wants the kids she
thinks the south is great we've traveled
the south i think you know life is a
little slower a little simpler hey look
we couldn't afford to live to buy our
house now the market has gone so crazy
right you know all right so here's why i
asked the question
if if it's not gonna go away if she's
not gonna keep bringing this up
then you're gonna have to get realistic
about what a move looks like
and how you're going to make the money
you want to make and get that you're
going to have to really consider that i
mean it's
you could put her off on this and go hey
i don't know but i mean that's the key
issue i'm open to it i'm open to it okay
i just don't feel like we'll have it you
know i'm painting my picture with the
dave ramsey
saving that 401k hit the roth right do
all these things and i'm finally
starting to see some traction and i'm
just scared that i've got it too good i
think you have a false narrative i i
think you need some more facts i know
you've done some research and i'm not
doubting you but i think there's a false
narrative that you can't make the money
you make now and also find a really
great investment strategy whether it's
through the school system are you doing
it yourself george speak to the i think
he's hung up on that 401k and i
understand why sure well there's free
money there but here's the thing you've
got a lot going on you've got a pile of
debt to clean up are you are you
investing past the 10 or is that it
um i've been doing a few hundred a month
and i've been doing a few hundred in the
raw okay well you're
currently you're following brett's plan
because our plan says you're pausing all
investing while we get rid of the debt
and you have a fully funded emergency
fund do you guys have an emergency fund
uh no we just have a thousand we're
still on baby step two so to your point
my question is should
i'm worried about losing out on the
compound interest if i stop investments
to pay off this fifty three thousand
dollar heloc and that's if i go crazy at
it it's going to take me if you were
worried about compound interest you
would have been investing when you were
22.
and so let's not be worried about that
right now let's be worried about
cleaning up the debt because then you're
not going to be investing 10 plus 100
you're going to be investing 15
and you're going to be investing for
your kids college and have all that
money for those five sweet kids of yours
to go to college debt-free and for you
to pay off your household they're on
their own for college
oh they're on their own
i was trying
do you have credit cards car payment
nothing else
nothing no that's what i thought so the
heloc is only dead and we've dug
ourselves out of that so you know what
do you mean you dug yourself out well
you haven't oh you mean you had more i'm
saying we've we've recently come to this
spot where we have paid off we got rid
of the car with the pain that we've come
here we're doing better we've got the
heloc and the mortgage left that's it
yeah okay he's worked his way down to
the heloc sure i look yeah george my
wife wants more space for the kids i
listen no dude let me just tell you
something right now your wife wants out
of utah the more space for the kids is
the secondary i know
listen dude i've been married almost 24
years
i think you've got more homework to do
you can invest okay if you sell the
house george here's where i'm going on
the financial i already got the math if
he sells the house
and they have a really huge they pay off
the heloc pay off the house they got a
huge down payment in a house in the
southeast you'll have 300k even after
closing a huge down payment and you can
get caught up on the investment strategy
whether or not the school's got a great
plan or not am i right george yes you
need to be investing 15 percent of your
income i don't want you relying on one
certain employer for your retirement
plan you need to be doing this out of
your own business i get that and so you
get i love the free money it's a great
plan and the truth is cost of living in
the south may be a lot cheaper than
where you're at so that's 72
making 55.60 might feel just the same
because of cost of living
especially when you have a 300 000 down
payment and now your mortgage is real
small if one at all now you feel like
you're really
yeah listen you got to do your research
man the south has got all kinds of great
guys
i moved to the south from the north and
i'll tell you game changer he's not
going back folks this is a boston boy
who loves the southeast
uh
cell move to the south happy wife happy
life no debt investing i'm a brainer i'm
actually excited
yeah
i'm telling you right now more research
is needed
i've come up with excuses to keep that
401k that is not the big top plate
all right good stuff george thank you
for the call brett more ramsey show
coming right up
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
um
[Music]
all right america welcome back to the
ramsay show thrilled to have you with us
as we talk about your life your money
your work your relationships i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell we are here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five
two two five so many of you been filing
your taxes with the same software for
years
but i ask you are you sick and tired of
all the add-on fees you've probably seen
all the tax software ads saying it's
free to do your taxes with the big
companies but the reality is
that for most people it's not free by
the time you realize you don't meet the
free criteria you've put in too much of
your time to start over somewhere else
so you pay up
people are making a killing off of you
we think you deserve better so that's
why we're offering ramsey smart tax so
you can file your taxes online without
paying more than you'd expect ramsey
smart tax includes every form you need
no hidden fees no surprises we even have
a promo code right now so you can file
your federal taxes for free and if you
prefer
to have priority support and extended
audit protection you can go with our
premium version for just 20 bucks if
you're ready to ditch all the other guys
surprising fees and save on your taxes
go to ramsey solutions dot com slash
smart tax and get started today that's
ramsay solutions dot com slash smart tax
all right jess is up in milwaukee
wisconsin jess how can we help
hi how are you guys doing today we're
having a blast what are you doing
oh lord my mind's just racing
so
um i just wanted to try and source
through kind of a shortish long-term-ish
goal that i have my husband and i have
and i want to
i need help in having a plan of when or
roundabouts
uh i can quit my job okay
um my husband might be
well more than likely is getting a
promotion here that's going to be
replacing my income wow um
we are on baby step six right now good
for you and
thank you uh we have a mortgage balance
right now of 274 thousands
um and have 1.3 in investments wow
[Music]
we don't we we don't want to pull and
pay like a capital gains tax on there
to pay off the mortgage we want we feel
and a lot of it was inherited by his
father who's passed away um years ago
um but we feel like his dad would want
us to work to pay off the house rather
than just you know here what is this
what is your income um
what will it be he's going to replace
your salary with this promotion so
what's the new number going to be income
wise both of you together um so right
now we're making about 81 000 a year
um and then he probably will bid in for
about 120
a year in salary so what will be the
combined income
when he gets the
promotion um if we were to combine we'd
be at probably about um well he'd be at
like 120 at b so about 160. we combined
all of it yeah yeah good i just wanted
to know all right so let's move us
forward now to this i love the way you
described it short-termish long-termish
goal i think we're talking about a dream
here what's the dream yeah for you what
is it i want i i want to stop working
i am fed up with my industry
it's just it's very hostile and
especially with colbit i had to
shut my business down
last year just because
colvin stuff and also just it was a
smart move
to do before you know all the inflation
and the rent increases in my area have
just gone through the roof and
are you doing this now or you shut it
down and reopened it what do you do
no so i'm i'm a massage therapist so i
closed down my business and then i've
been working um in a higher end like
kind of a spa area and it's just been
it's been very hostile and that's how
it's been throughout my whole career
i've been doing this 20 years i'm sorry
about that yeah so it's the dream to
just quit and go home or to quit and go
go do something else
well that's kind of what my husband and
i have talked about he's like hey you
know if i get this job you could just
potentially quit and then dabble in
things to try and figure out what it is
that you'd like to do
but i'm kind of feeling like you know
maybe if i just take a couple of years
off and just kind of
be a
at-home wife all the time we don't have
kids and but i part of me feels like
well am i wrong in thinking that i
should take some time off and then just
figure out what i want to do i mean no
no no no okay and it sounds like your
husband doesn't think that's wrong
either he's actually even saying do it
and dabble
you're going i just don't want to do
anything for two years that might change
you might get home six months later and
go i'm ready for some dabbling but the
reality is there's nothing wrong with
what you're doing and financially you
guys are in such great shape that with
his increase in income and if you decide
to dabble down the line you guys can
easily pay this house off
so is that why you called permission to
leave
yes
it is granted first of all you didn't
need it george granted george i think we
grant her permission yeah the reason why
we teach the baby steps is not because
we are obsessed with money it's because
it gives us freedom and options and
meaning and that's exactly what you guys
get to experience now i would still have
a goal to pay off this house quickly
maybe say hey we're going to put 60k on
the house every year and we're going to
pay this thing off in less than five
years sure awesome goal absolutely so i
would stay the course on that not lose
focus on finishing out these baby steps
so you can live and give like no one
else but the idea of her being able to
do that and go home and figure it out
and find that dream of hers whether
that's staying home or going back to
work eventually that's amazing most
people don't have that kind of
flexibility yeah so jess are you hearing
what george is saying he's absolutely
right because you're not even though
you're gonna potentially for a season
whatever it looks like
not make any money your husband's
promotion is replacing that so you guys
should be able to continue keeping on
marching towards paying that house off
and honoring uh what you said your
husband's father's wishes are do you
understand that so we keep moving
forward on the baby steps get to baby
step seven right yeah i just want to
make sure that i'm not being selfish
i just don't want to work right now no
wait no but see that's not what you're
saying i'm so glad you brought that up
you are not saying jess
i'm just not going to work right now
what you're saying is i've been in a
toxic
environment
for 20 years that's what you said
earlier in the call
you were in such a great financial
position because of the fact that you
and your husband walk the baby steps out
and you're in a season where you need
that break
how good is it right i mean what good is
it jess
to be in baby step six moving towards
baby step seven get into baby step seven
and be absolutely burned out
that's not fun at all
no
nor is it necessary
right and the thing that i'm so close
that it's like do i just suffer through
it because that was the other thought is
working until the house gets paid off no
okay okay all right so i'm glad you
brought this up how much money again do
you make as a massage therapist
i'm about it depends but let's just say
this year i made 40 42k okay great yeah
what if you take two three months you
fill in the blank i don't care
we get out of the toxic situation we get
some rest we get healthy your head gets
clear
and now you can begin to go well what
could i do
no pressure for a long-term career
commitment here but what could i do
using your husband's word dabbling
and actually making 20 000 or 25 or 40.
for heaven's sakes you've got companies
like target and amazon and walmart just
to name a few best buy that are paying
15 to 20 an hour
no pressure no toxicity i'm not seeing
you go to work for those places i'm
saying what if you dabbled and you did
speed up paying off the house but it
wasn't a long-term commitment it wasn't
anything other than i'm just helping out
pay off the debt a little bit faster but
i still have time to think and dream
isn't that possible jess
yeah it is possible then consider that
okay thank you you bet but you need to
leave okay the only massages you're
doing are for the hubs
and that may be debatable george i like
that plan though that's not a bad idea i
like it for him i'm trying to help him
out a little bit but if you're sure if
your wife is a masseuse and vince over
20 years is that the last thing she
wants to do if you're a chef
professionally you don't get home and go
i'd love to cook a big meal right now
that's what i'm saying so that's what
i'm getting i don't want to assume
anything yeah you know it's a great
question oh man and that's what i love
about the baby steps it prepares you for
something like this where you go we can
do this
we have the margin not even think twice
about it yeah baby step six gonna pay
the house off whether she works or not
it's gonna happen soon really great
stuff jess thank you so much for the
call yeah you need to get healthy get
free of that toxicity and then move
forward all right george you're not
going anywhere i'm not going anywhere
this is the ramsey show don't you go
anywhere
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues
i'm ken coleman
george campbell joins me in studio is my
co-host and we are here to help you out
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight
eight two five five two two five blinds
dot com one hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure and i have and would or pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best deal today's question comes from
catherine in florida she asks i've been
working in the mortgage field since
2007. i burned out in 2017 and went to
work for a non-profit housing counseling
agency we were able to adjust the budget
and stay on our path to become debt free
in 2020 i returned to the mortgage
industry i'm more successful now than i
ever thought possible and i'm on pace to
make over 85 thousand dollars this year
i love my customers and i feel like this
is my passion but the corporate culture
has me yearning to return to the
non-profit sector even if i would only
make 38 000 a year with minimal growth
potential we owe 267 thousand 000 on our
home and i have 40 000 in student loan
debt we're 40 years old with four kids
my husband makes 40 000 a year we don't
have enough in retirement savings and
that scares me too what advice would you
give about my career path all right i
love this question and catherine i think
what i see here is your heart
and if you're not careful your heart's
going to try to talk your head out of of
being smart and usually i see it's the
other way around george where people's
heads will try to talk their heart out
of doing something and so here's what i
mean
um
you're not burned out anymore you're
healthy you're back in the mortgage
industry and you know this is your
passion but you're talking about the
corporate culture and the corporate
culture is very different i certainly
understand that than what you
experienced when you were in the
nonprofit world
but the reality is you have some big
time financial responsibilities and
obligations and you've got some more
work to do
so
i want you to stay where you are
and you're going to deal with the
corporate culture you're going to change
your mindset to you know what i love the
other
environment better i can get there
eventually you're only
40 years of age
so i think you do
two things
first i told you stay where you are
keep making good money keep moving up
keep walking out the baby steps
but
how can you volunteer
how can you spend a little bit of time
let you determine what that looks like
each month
in that non-profit world
giving of yourself
uh investing in that environment and
getting a little bit of a taste of that
to keep that heart full
while you're doing the corporate
mortgage gig that's that's what i want
you to do and then with the i and the
mindset
that in the future when we're totally
debt free when i can take an income hit
because i've planned for it and my life
now being debt free is adjusted to the
point that this is gravy anyway then we
could go full time into that nonprofit
world so i think it's perspective and i
think it's patience yeah and i'll give
you some math to support that right now
according to what you told us you guys
make 125 combined and you have 40 000
in student loan debt so like ken said
i'm sticking this out and i'm paying off
this 40 000 in under a year with that
income as fast as possible and then when
you make the switch when that happens
you would go down to about 78 if that's
a path you want to pursue but at that
point you're at baby step six and you're
working on paying off the house so i'd
continue to have that as a goal
and like ken was mentioning maybe
there's there's some mix and maybe you
could find another environment that
isn't non-profit where you do feel like
it's fulfilling because you're telling
me here is
it's just a it's corporate culture
this is this is the issue here's the
corporate culture who knows what that
means it could mean a thousand things
but you're telling me there's not a
mortgage company that has a good culture
i mean our friends down here at
churchill mortgage oh sure great place
to work yeah i think i think what we're
hearing in that is that there the
non-profit experience she's had before
the nonprofit housing is the way i think
she addressed it
um and and that is um yes non-profit
housing counseling agency
she is delineating between well if i'm
the mortgage interest here i'm helping
people who can afford it hopefully
get a house they're part of the kind of
natural american dream when i was over
here we were helping people who
never dreamed of a home and what it did
for them
and so there's just much more heart
engagement there still both great and so
that's what's going on there yeah it is
it's some corporate culture but it's
more
the impact and the stories uh
really are affecting her heart more over
here and that's why i'm saying do
something over there you can still help
and volunteer
maybe even get a part-time job over
there who cares but you got to stay the
course as you said there's a theme in
today's show debt holds you back from
opportunity and the faster you can get
out of debt the faster you can get
through these baby steps the more
opportunity you have can i can i can i
edit that please
debt
delays
our dreams oh that's good
that's a ken coleman quote right there
that is one people will tweet i will say
that yeah that's way more tweetable all
right
okay very nice we'll see who's even on
twitter even more who knows it's like a
tree falling in the middle of the world
that's true yeah there you go just bots
these days all right let's go to andrew
in lexington kentucky andrew how can we
help
hey uh thanks for taking my call
my wife uh kristen and i have been
working the baby steps we've been on
baby step two since the beginning of
2020.
uh we paid off worked together and paid
off um a little over seventy thousand so
far good job
um have about sixty thousand remaining
so um my wife is a teacher she works in
the school system and she
um wants to get out of school system we
had a little baby in july so
congratulations
thank you thank you
so she wants to be out of that job and
also be home with him which i totally
support
um
with without her income i kind of
project
july by the time she's done with her job
we'll have 42 000 left on the debt
my question is we have about i think we
could probably get 100 000 out of our
home our current home
we could sell our home
pay off all my student loan debt
have a twenty thousand dollar emergency
fund
and then have about a thirty five
thousand dollar
head store head start towards baby step
three b
and then our plan would be to rent for a
year and save up to purchase another
home
and i guess i'm just wondering if that
that plan
gives us a lot of freedom kind of like
you've been talking about this hour yeah
george what do you think i mean i love
this plan a lot of people just aren't
willing to sell and as long as you guys
are willing to be patient and rent for a
year which at all indicators point to
yes here then i love this plan i do too
yeah now if you're gonna go turn around
try to buy something tomorrow you're
gonna find yourself in a tizzy in this
market
uh but let me ask you this what's your
household income
um about 126. 126. and you guys paid off
70 000 in two years making 126. correct
yes yeah and you got 60k left
right so if you stayed the course it
would be less than two years to go
yeah
but you want her to be able to stay home
when she has the baby
right right
he's six months old now um she went at
the end of the school year she'd love to
stay home with him
okay and i totally support that she's
still working right now or she
she is currently yes okay
would there be harm in her staying maybe
a year longer in the workforce before
staying home
um it's kind of been a bad situation
just between
she has she's a tough job she's worked
in special education with students with
moderate severe disabilities yeah it
really takes a toll on you
and that's her heart is just to be home
with him which i want her to be able to
do
well george the way i look at this uh
andrew i'm i'm seeing one year
difference so there's a lot of a lot of
moving around
pain in the butt you know extra expenses
to sell a house
pack it all up move to an apartment
right
um and it saves you a year
you know versus you you know doing what
you can while she's at home maybe you
pick up a second job i i like where
you're going george there's a couple
options here but he's willing to make
the sacrifices and to that i say touche
let's do this thing i would do it andrew
if you want to know what i do with your
scenario i'd do it because the baby's
six months old the baby doesn't know
you could be in an apartment for a year
if you needed to extend it a year and a
half or two years you get a two bedroom
apartment it's no big deal
uh and you guys can keep saving up i i
like the movie you're leapfrogging the
baby steps and doing it the right way i
like the fast forward button most people
are just not willing to do it andrew so
i applaud you for being willing to do
whatever it takes to put your family in
a integration i say do it andrew you
guys are young uh the baby's not gonna
know anything and he doesn't care right
it's fantastic baby doesn't care that's
the key he doesn't you know he'll go
where he's a baby yeah put him in the
car seat he doesn't know
he doesn't know how big the room is or
if it's an apartment or a house all
right great stuff hey thank you george
want to say thank you to our team in the
control booth for making the show happen
i want to thank you america this is your
show it is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell we're here this hour to
take your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the toll-free
number it's free
triple eight
eight two five
five two two five george you're ready to
go i'm ready all right let's do it let's
go to andrea in denver colorado andre
how can we help
hi thank you guys for taking my call i'm
a huge fan thank you
how can we help today
i wanted to give you a scenario and
hopefully you can give my husband and i
some guidance
he
was
my husband is burnt out on his job he
was a combat
military for eight years and then went
straight into law enforcement and has
been doing that for nine years wow
he
would like to move out of that and move
towards
mortgages
and
we are in baby step two we have a car
loan that's about twenty two thousand
and right now i was doing some math and
um
we need about thirty eight thirty nine
hundred dollars to run our household and
he gets a va payment um for twenty three
hundred dollars so fifteen hundred
dollar difference
and um another thing that we were
hoping to do was we don't love our house
we were thinking
if we move
um we sell this house pay off our car
have a big emergency fund and get into a
different house so he can make that
transition quicker
because like i said he's just really
burnt out
um do you think that that's a feasible
plan um i think one of the things that
scares me is just having that income up
in the air where it's not as secure as
what he has now
is that a
is that something that's
reasonable or am i just being fearful of
change well i'm gonna have george walk
through the numbers let's have george
walk you through the money
and and then we'll walk through the
professional side and what that income
could look like and how long that's
gonna take because i think if you get
really confident and george walks you
through is this a good move financially
to do all these things then we can kind
of plan so george walker through that so
what i'm hearing andrea is
you need 18 000 of net income
at this point to keep keep everything
going
right no we need it's like a fifteen
hundred dollar difference yeah you said
a month
per month yes okay if you multiply that
out by twelve months it's eighteen
thousand dollars oh i'm sorry okay well
i i misunderstood your question as well
i'm just saying this is not a huge chunk
of money you could go work a part-time
job and make this money so on that part
i don't want you to be fearful because
there's not a five thousand dollar gap
here and we can't pay the bills so this
is definitely doable what is the car
worth
uh the car's worth about 38. we um
actually
found you guys
bought the car found you guys and then
since october have paid down to about
22. fantastic
so if you sell the car today you've got
uh
16 there how much is the house worth
so the house is worth between uh 650 and
700 and we owe 360. oh wow very nice
and we don't love the home it's
something that was already on our minds
yeah you do
there you go it's a great problem to
have would you guys be looking to buy a
house again immediately because i know
denver's real estate market is pretty
wild
so we're actually out
denver is the closest city we're
actually uh four hours away from it we
would be looking to um to buy but we
would keep a chunk of that down payment
to just kind of
have some margins
and you guys have already run these
numbers sounds like to me
i have yes um i guess what
where my fear is coming from is we have
gotten a lot of feedback saying
well as a mortgage
officer you could be making money in a
year or you could be making money in
five years and that's where i think my
fear is coming from and i don't know how
reasonable that is
um or if i'm just being fearful but he's
he's really at the point where he's you
know i heard you and john deloney talk
about that anxiety piece and that
sleeping piece when you're just totally
burned down and he's there
so we're trying to really work hard to
figure out what we can do to get him to
a better spot sure okay so
i'll just dive in right there so you
guys can sell this house
sell the car i mean you could you have
multiple options here and all of a
sudden all that debt is gone you reduce
your expenses big time that's great and
it will allow
you and he
to sleep better at night knowing he's in
a transition
but before we even talk about all that
all that makes sense george do you agree
yeah okay he's on board so he's on
george is on board it makes sense to do
that you don't like the house anyway i
think it's a no-brainer to sell the
house and if you want to keep the car
you can keep this if you want to sell
that yeah you can pay it off and you
guys rent a year if you want to take
your time that all makes sense i want to
address your fear
of him moving into the mortgage industry
being a mortgage officer and what's that
income going to look like so the fear
that you're feeling right now is i think
largely based on the unknown i think
you've gotten some opinions and i think
what he has to do
your husband uh if he's on board with
this and i'm assuming he is that he
wants to do this he knows he needs to go
do his research talk to multiple people
who are winning in that space
in that mortgage officer space
and he needs to get multiple opinions
i want three minimum
right so that he can cut away i got
three different people
uh what are the commonalities in their
recommendations uh and then what are the
outliers i'm gonna go do my homework
because if he just follows this out and
he realized okay if i get with a company
like this who's got a great training
program uh and i know that maybe one
company will offer something like this
which is uh maybe a base that gets you
started or a draw
and get you going that first year here's
what we can say is a safe prediction of
what you'd make in year one or in the
first six months this is just a
fact-finding mission
it doesn't need to be any scarier than
that do you understand what i'm saying
andrea
yes because look financially you guys
have got great options right now
and so
we just go find out
what does the transition look like let
me let me give you a couple of questions
that uh if you've got something to write
with i want you and your husband to walk
through these questions together you
ready
yes okay
so we want to figure out specifically
what does he need to learn from a
qualification standpoint so what
certifications is he going to need all
right there's there's you got to figure
that out then we've got to say okay how
much time is that going to take
how much money is it gonna cost three
simple little questions there what does
he need to do to get qualified from a
just certifications process
um how much is it gonna cost to do that
cost is not your issue but you just
wanna put all this together and then how
much time is it gonna take
those are the three pieces here of your
plan and then if he goes and does the
other things i just recommend and he
gets good feedback and he knows all
right
i know that we can make this and this is
what we'd have to do it's going to help
you on the rest of that financial
formula to decide do we immediately go
buy or do we rent for a little bit and
pad our stats does that make sense
it does it does that's really helpful
yeah you can do this
sell the house
you got options again george the theme
it's the theme of the day debt
holds back the dreams it delays the
dreams and this could fast forward
everything for this man we love the fast
forward button around here when you do
it right i really do and would you thank
your husband for his service to our
country as well as his community that uh
a lot of stuff there and to put your
life on the line for others is is
commendable and he is a hero thank you
for the call this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me 130 000
all thanks to what i learned at bethel
tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell we are here to answer your
questions about your life
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five tax
season is upon us i know
everybody try to calm down out there no
one likes doing their taxes especially
when you realize
what the big software companies are up
to every year these companies lure you
in by saying you can file your taxes for
free
then when you're knee-deep in the filing
process they sucker punch you with up
charges loan offers and credit card
pitches there's a better way to do it
folks it's called
ramsey smart tax this is our online tax
filing software with ramsey smart tax
you get all the deductions all the forms
and every tax break you deserve the best
part is the price our price is already
much lower than the leading competitor
and
we don't have the hidden fees
plus this year we have a promo code that
will truly make it free to file your
federal taxes go to ramseysolutions.com
smart tax to get your promo code file
without the surprises that's ramsay
solutions dot com
slash
smart tax all right huntington west
virginia zack is on the line zach how
can we help
hello
hi yeah all right yeah so i was just
calling because it's about kind of like
career goals and education to get there
so
i i have two scholarships to do
different schools i've already got a
bachelor's degree this is for grad
school and um
me and my wife have been discussing this
and we we're not really sure where we're
at on it um
one of them is a master's in uh
christian studies which would lead which
would pay for most if i wanted to get a
masters of divinity would get most of it
and my goal is to eventually teach
at the seminary level at least at bible
college get a phd in that
or
get a master i have another scholarship
to get a masters in
in education which currently right now i
teach sixth grade so that would it would
give me a pay raise
it would take me up from 45 000 to about
50 000.
um
i was wondering and i could eventually
get the phd after that obviously too but
it would be much faster for me to get
the phd if i did the
christian studies first i was wondering
what you guys thought about that which
would be the wise choice to make to me
the wise choice zack is to take the
straightest most direct path
right okay fastest i was never good in
math but i do remember
the fastest like the shortest dist
between two points is
straight line
and so it seems to me that for you to
get the phd you already said it
um then then one path is very clear the
mdiv is the best path to the phd and the
phd is the
destination for you academically to do
what you want to do so i wouldn't delay
any time you know and it sounds to me
like maybe you're
the conversation between your wife
and you on this choice
is about well if we get the masters over
here we get a pay bump is that probably
what's going on here
yeah it's a
she's interested in stability adding
more stability so yeah but it's how much
more how much more money
five thousand dollars after how long
two more years of a master's program or
how long is it gonna take to get that
five thousand dollar bump um well once i
get the master's program it goes up the
year that i start with that oh okay so
pretty quickly
yeah all right so here's what i would do
so here's what i do i'm going to hand
this to george i want to know what
george thinks but george my mind for
zach is zach needs to go okay he knows
what the straightest line is
it's the mdiv to the phd
but his wife's going hey there's a five
thousand dollar bump the minute you take
the masters in education
george my mindset is you take five
thousand dollars gross
they're gonna get a pretty good idea
what the taxes are on that and then you
divide that by 12 months it's not that
much more money you could say to your
wife i'm going to get the quickest path
to the phd in the dream and i'll go work
a little extra to bring in that money
she thought was going to be so awesome
and stable
my thought was i could mow lawns over a
summer and make five grand easy so it's
not nothing but it's not life-changing
either if you said it it's gonna be a 20
grand bump i'd say let's have this
conversation now are these both full
scholarships what are we talking here
so one is a full scholarship uh to get
and the md what would i get is a
master's in christian studies at the
baptist college of florida but then i
would transfer those credits to a place
to get an mdip because that's what i
have to get to get a phd right or i have
a i have another full scholarship to
liberty university
um which would get me a
master's in christian education
um
and that would give me that but it
wouldn't but if i if i did that i'd have
to take a lot more extra classes to get
to the phd to get to where i would
qualify another report
so i'm gonna go with the one that's the
full scholarship that's going to take
the least amount of time and credits
yeah there it is
but i mean the money thing is not that
big of a deal he's got to be able to
present this to his wife
what looks like five thousand dollars
isn't actually five thousand dollars
yeah and when we look at what the actual
what i'm trying to do zach is help you
because i've been married a long time
and and you've got to be able to present
this to your wife she's she's presenting
an idea based on safety so you've got to
actually meet her there yeah and go if i
had done this it would i'd have to take
more classes would take me longer blah
blah blah blah and the 5 000 is actually
going to turn into this in our actual
paycheck in our actual budget so then we
go i can make that another way yep and
i'm willing to do that now let me let me
ask you this do you guys have any debt
yeah we've got some debt we got about um
50 000
what kind of debt is that
student loans entirely okay but it
sounds like we're done accruing more
debt at this point
yeah we're not doing that anymore okay
and what's the household income
the household income is about a hundred
thousand okay so your wife is working
outside the home as well
she's an engineer oh my gosh fantastic
this makes me feel better yes does it
change my advice though yeah advice
still stays the same but i do want you
to attack the student loan debt if
you're going to be able to you know cash
flow this master's experience don't let
this thing sit idle for too long
okay yeah i like it thank you man yeah
appreciate the call very exciting uh
you know congratulations zach on two
full rides it's amazing sharp guy i
never got one full ride george they
don't just hand those out ken not to me
or you at least i don't know i think
you're a little smarter than i am thank
you yeah all right let's go to jonathan
next in dallas texas jonathan how can we
help
hey how are you guys doing uh we're
having a blast what's going on with you
good so my wife and i we just uh we're
both debt free um we're 26 and 28 and uh
we just sold our house down here in
dallas in dallas area for a profit of a
hundred thousand dollars uh after moving
expenses and um and that kind and fees
um and we wanted to know uh what would
be the best way to spend um that or to
spend or invest that uh one hundred
thousand
um we're moving up to the boise area uh
so a little bit further away
and uh we looked to buy a house but kind
of in the future um
so we're just kind of wanting to see
what the best route is with that money
okay are you guys debt free
yes sir we are debt free and do you have
a fully funded emergency fund of three
to six months
not yet now you do once you've got this
hundred grand you're going to take a
portion of that and set that aside so
that's one thing you're going to do with
the money
and then with the rest of the money you
guys will begin investing and you'll
begin putting away money for your kids
college do you have kids
no we do plan on on uh having kids here
pretty soon a couple of them i kind of
thought about maybe
um putting started investing in uh like
roth iras for their education just in
case they decide to take a different
plan kind of frees up that money for it
for them
is that a good idea i mean personally i
stick to esa's and 529s and if they
don't use it someone in the family can
use it and this can go towards a lot of
different things certificate programs if
you or your wife want to have any kind
of continued education there's a lot of
ways to use that money and you're going
to be better off putting it there than
the roth ira so that's my take on that
but when it comes to the rest of this
money i would be socking that away for a
down payment on this next house and if
it's gonna be in the next year two even
three years i would just put it away in
a high yield savings account
which is not going to help grow your
money but it will protect it so don't
put it into the market right now that's
not what you want to do i would rent for
a year once you get to boise figure out
where you want to live let the market
cool down a little bit and then make the
decision once you guys keep stacking the
cash
i love that that's what i would do oh
yeah george get this one man's opinion
yeah 100 000 minus whatever that three
to six months number is and that's what
you begin to save on top of great advice
uh how exciting and we can't stress
enough for a young couple like this with
no kids i absolutely would rent the
first year yeah moving into a new area
we call them dinks ken dual income no
kids oh it's a great life is that what
we call them yeah that's good
hey i'll tell you what else is good more
of your calls coming up this is the
ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague
george campbell the phone number to jump
in as we help you with your questions
about life and money and relationships
and work
it is triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to milwaukee
wisconsin joshua joins us there joshua
how can we help
hey how are you guys doing we're having
a blast what's going on
awesome i had a question about my
relationship and uh kind of how the
financial aspect of everything fits into
it
i've been with a girl you know about a
year and a half and i love her and i'm
looking at engagement
but we haven't discussed finances in
detail and
i know there's a bit of an income gap
there and i was just kind of wondering
when and how that subject should be
approached
great question
great question so let me ask you this
what you said there's an income gap how
do you know that
um i she asked me to help do her taxes
last year um i'm an investment advisor
and tax advisor cool so you know her
income but she doesn't know yours
yeah and there's no big secret the
conversations just never come up
yeah so what is the conversation like
around money so far
um you know it's just something we just
split expenses when we go out and you
know there's never any kind of concern
on my part or even hers
but we have not gone in depth in any way
shape or form you know as far as what i
have and what i make and
um that kind of thing well without
giving you a specific timeline i'll say
this what's more important than the
numbers are the values
and if you guys value the same things
financially if you guys both want to
remain debt-free become debt-free invest
for the future those are the things that
tell me that you will have longevity as
a couple versus who makes what but if
the fear is i make a lot more than her
is this going to change the relationship
is that part of the equation
you know i'm not overly concerned about
that but it's something that's in the
back of my mind you know i don't think
that she values that kind of thing more
than me
great values as a person she's awesome
and neither of us have any debt anymore
um
so i guess i was just kind of wondering
when when's appropriate before you get
engaged after you get engaged
sure well here's here's the funny thing
she's already aired everything about her
financial life because you did her taxes
so clearly she's very open and honest
about this stuff and i don't think it's
a bad thing for you to do that as well
but i do think it's wise for for you
guys to be engaged before having you
know very specific conversations when it
comes to numbers because we don't
recommend combining your finances until
you're married and that's really when it
starts to matter
sure
but ken may have a totally different
approach what's your take on this guy
you know i think it's
i think you're very thoughtful on this
and i think there might be some fears i
think you've addressed the financial
stuff
you know i think you have to joshua kind
of wrestle with what are you afraid of
based on the information you've given us
you know do you think that i know you
love her
but i just heard some doubt about maybe
even the long-term
viability of this relationship
because of how she looks at money and
how you look at money am i am i reading
into that or did i hear some of that
no i you know i mean i guess
it's in the back of my mind but um
it's probably more so from past
experiences i've had nothing to do with
her you know i'd hate to
put that on her it's it's probably more
just in my life experiences i've been
burned in the past you know everybody
has what does that mean for you like you
what do you mean you disclosed your
income and they used you for your money
or
no not necessarily i mean i just had in
the past i've been surrounded by some
shallower people and she is by no means
shallow it's just maybe that's why i'm
kind of struggling with the whole idea
of
disclosing it fully to somebody that's
not say a business partner or you know
an immediate family member
well i think i'm hearing some trust
issues based on your past that's pretty
normal you got hurt
you know there's there's some trauma
involved with what's happened to you in
the past and so you have to get healthy
with that
and move on from it and then go okay
what have i learned so i can be smart
but as i begin to grow deeper in my
relationship with her and i share my
finances i mean what's the worst that
can happen
do you know what i mean do you think
she's gonna go on facebook and share it
with everybody
no no you know so play this out you know
what what is the worst that can happen
if i share my finances and i think
actually as you as you get comfortable
doing this and again i think george is
right you guys are dating right now so i
don't think this has to happen now but
if you get to that point and you become
engaged and and maybe even before we get
engaged i think this is a great time
it's not about showing her everything in
your finances it's more about talking
about your views on
finances
and your values around money and if she
is naive that's a big difference than
shallow
see shallow
yeah okay good so you get what i'm
saying there i think shallow is one
thing
naivete and not you know kind of having
any knowledge or experience with money
is very different i think it's you begin
to teacher and share with things and not
be intense about it
but
have conversations about it as you would
maybe about eventually having kids or
a religion or pilot or whatever you
would in a relationship you begin to
talk about it holistically and see how
she feels about it
and if you feel there's still concerns
then you have to take that serious but
right now i'm not seeing a lot of red
flags
sure yeah appreciate the call young man
very thoughtful yeah very mature right
yeah i think that's great let's go now
to huntsville alabama nathan is there
nathan how can we help
ken george what's going on you what's
happening
well
right now i'm currently in college at
community college and
i've been kind of reconsidering my
options a little bit and
you know i want to get into uh
programming and that that side
technology but
i'm just seeing that you know there's
some better ways that i can go besides
like a four-year degree and all that and
it's kind of like reconsidering doing
like an associate's degree since you
know community colleges are way cheaper
than you know universities but
you know
i just like to just go ahead and see
if this is a good move for me to do
right now so i can get experience and
you know move up later if i choose to do
so and
you know yeah okay so
do you have any experience right now in
this area of technology that you want to
go into even if it's entry level
experience
um
no i i do have some you know knowledge
of you know
programming and like like python and i'm
right now learning c plus plus and
that's good you know i created some
you know
minor projects on the side but nothing
like to where maybe an employer would
say
oh you you know your projects are you
know incredible let's go ahead and sure
well so if you're asking if i'm if i'm
putting this together you're going i'm
in college right now uh is it a smart
idea for me to stop at the you know
instead of pursue a technology degree or
computer science you fill in the gap uh
or the blank rather uh get an
associate's degree to community college
which you can cash flow it's a lot
cheaper a lot quicker and then you focus
on those certifications like you're
already taking that training and get
yourself enough certifications for entry
level which you can do even at this
young age they'll hire you right now
there are entry level positions once you
have the right certifications even on
the programming level um i think that's
a great move if that's what you
absolutely know you want to do and you
want to move up as a programmer and any
different kind of direction that that
could take you uh i can tell you right
now you do not need the computer science
degree it costs a lot of money takes a
lot of time you don't need it so yeah i
like that move
nathan how much time and money will it
cost you to switch majors at this point
uh
well
about maybe two years it would be the
you know maybe minimum of when i've been
able to acquaint my associates and
right now i have
you know about maybe
four thousand saved up for you know to
set aside to pack cash flow my way
through college
and you know you know i don't have any
other way scholarship but you know it's
that's not like truly top of my mind of
like what you get or major focus
you don't even need an associates
i just thought you were asking hey if i
want an associates which kind of sets me
up if i wanted to jump back on the
education path down the line should i do
that and i think yeah but the point is
you don't even need the associates to
get into the technology field
okay so
what are with some good
um certifications on the programming
side that i should be you know focusing
on yeah great question
i personally am not a programmer so i
can't roll them off the top of my head
but here's what i want you to do i want
you to find three or four programmers uh
in the area that you know have personal
connections to ask them those questions
go do your own research about what are
the most vital most relevant programming
certifications that make you versatile
in the technology field go research that
as well and then you're off and running
my man appreciate the call good stuff
don't move more of your calls coming up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show where we
help you win in your life with your
money your relationships your work
i'm ken coleman joined by george
campbell we're here for you the shower
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our scripture of the day comes from
job 34 32 teach me what i cannot see if
i have done wrong i will not do so again
our quote from john maxwell learn to say
no
to the good so you can say yes to the
best
triple eight eight two five
two is our phone number let's go to
greenville south carolina kevin is there
kevin how can we help
hey guys and good afternoon how are you
doing today we're having a blast what's
going on with you
oh no doing well doing well i just
wanted to call you guys and get your
advice um i've been uh i'm in baby step
four right now and i'm trying to um
start start doing some investing and
land and
so i i just got enough money in my ira
to actually start start investing and
taking a serious step into our vessel so
i wanted yours your opinion on if if i
should cash out some of my ira to
purchase a piece of land
um you know and i should say it's a it's
a rough ira so i don't have to worry
about the tax ship
all right how much is in the ira
uh i'm about to hit a hundred thousand
okay and what's this uh
property worth of the land that you want
to buy
so i though the first one that i'm
looking at is just six acres here in the
greenville area and it's about forty
five thousand dollars so it wouldn't be
all of my ira but it would be some of it
okay and how old are you
i am 34.
34 years old
all right and what are you planning on
doing with the land
just as an investment let it sit it's
just boring boring land basically just
buying land of what's left of it in
america
yes exactly that that's the american
dream
you got to get that dirt george yep now
is this a self-directed ira
uh it is not it is not a self-director
it's just a regular roth ira
okay well in that case you've got to be
using a self-directed roth ira to to buy
that kind of investment property um are
you planning on paying all the taxes and
all this because you're not of
retirement age what's your plan there
have you looked into the details
well since it's a roth ira i i i could
be misinformed here but all the taxes
are paid up in front so i wouldn't be
hit with any of the um any of the fees
as long as i don't take anything out
that is uh
that is not returned so any of the money
that the contractors
yeah the contributions that would only
be funding from my contribution sorry i
just don't want to unplug all of that
money that's growing for you with
compound interest right now at your age
at 34.
yeah you leave a hundred is my concern i
if i'm you honestly you've done so well
why can't you save up 45 000 and just
pay for this land in cash uh i
definitely could like i said it's just
it's just that's the vehicle that i had
at this moment for it um so that's that
was my thought process but i definitely
could it would probably take another
year or two to realize that goal
yeah i i'm with george kevin i i really
want you to consider what he's saying
because now you get a little both and as
opposed to well i got to just move right
now on this piece of land there's gonna
be a lot of land
you're in such good financial shape
you're sharp you work hard i hope you
hear what george is saying he's
absolutely right i wouldn't touch it i
mean your money's gonna double about
every seven years
and that's averaging you know ten
percent in the market and so
that hundred grand is going to turn into
200 without you touching it without you
adding a dime right
and right and and and just just to
clarify one thing i mean also
the but i would also be returning from
the land too right when i go to sell
maybe was my thought process we just
don't know
we don't know what the land's gonna do
versus the market on average for the
last you know 80 90 years and so there's
a lot of unknowns in this scenario i
hope your land doubles but that still is
going to be less than your account
doubling
so i would still say your account is the
better investment and at 34 man you got
so much time to let that thing grow and
you can save up in a year make that an
awesome goal to buy land in a year
they'll still be land out there and
it'll still be cheap if it's 45 right
now in 2022 it's not going to be too
much more in 2023
i understand okay yeah i love the goal
though i love the heart behind it man
yeah congratulations on getting with it
stay the course i like it george save it
up wait that year gives you more chance
to kind of see what's the right land
yeah you kind of get that fever and i'm
calling all those contributions and that
brought you work so hard yeah i'm with
you i don't want to do that yeah i like
that let's go to mark in dallas texas
now mark how can we help
yeah hey guys thanks for taking my call
sure so i am single 55 years old i have
been on
a step two in a debt uh repayment
journey for five and a half years paying
back 323 000
i'm down to
60 000 wow um
that's awesome mark that's getting with
it man
you're breaking up on us speak directly
into your phone
looks like we look mark are you there
did you go in a tunnel yeah yeah i'm
here all right so here's where we we
left off you had paid uh off uh over
three hundred thousand dollars you're
down to sixty thousand or so that's
where we lost you right yeah yeah and so
i
i
my question is
um
in this toxic work environment um
i can't do i can't deal with this
anymore
what's going on
what's happening
it's just a
really toxic environment yeah and i can
hear it all over you what what what
what's happening
um
just the the bullying
um
who's bullying is it co-workers or your
leader
what it what does bullying sound like
and look like what's happening
either get this done or i'm gonna look
for somewhere else
wow what kind of work are you doing
i'm a technical project manager
yeah um
i'm so sorry mark
you feel threatened you feel threatened
yeah you feel threatened every day don't
you
yeah yeah um
so let me [ __ ] collect myself here um
i have two rental properties that are
paid off great um
what are they
three
worth
thousand a piece wow um and i have three
hundred thousand in a uh traditional
ira
uh and so my question is
should i just sell the rental properties
and get out of this entire thing and
simplify my life
well
i'll let george weigh in on that one i
will say that if it helps you i have an
opinion and i think if it helps you
leave this toxic environment and get
healthy at the age of 55 and also get
rid of that 60 000 in debt i really like
it i i think this is a combination of
money and i think it's a combination of
mental and emotional health george yeah
if this job is this if if this money and
the debt is what's keeping you in this
toxic job then i'm selling one of the
rentals because it's not worth going in
there one more day but if you can go
switch to another job because technical
project managers are in high demand high
demand and you can go work somewhere
where your leader doesn't make you feel
so small
i might do that first before i go
selling off the rentals and dealing with
the hassle of that and losing some of
that cash flow especially as you head
into your retirement years so i'd take a
pause here and go do i hate this field
do i hate this job is it my leader and
it sounds like if you switched to a
place where you were valued because
we've got technical project managers
here at ramsey solutions and we love
them and we care about them and we never
threaten them and make them feel small
yeah i i agree with you i don't disagree
with george i i'm fine with selling one
i tend to always go for the fastest
solution i felt his voice change when he
said i could sell one and i could be
completely free out of this thing and i
that's why i say do that you have worked
and busted your tail five and a half
year journal five and a half years you
still got 60 grand to go you can always
get another rental property you're going
to easily pay off the debt get the
emergency fund fat and fully funded come
on mark how would that feel
oh my god yeah
and you're still going to have money
left over
do you have a mortgage currently on your
primary residence well i i do have uh my
primary mortgage um and the other thing
is i've got about thirty thousand
dollars in cash um so i i literally was
uh sitting there last night just i throw
everything up and throw everything at
the debt and and leave yes
you've done the numbers i want you to
get a better job better environment and
i want you to pay off all this debt and
get a whole fresh start that's what i
want you to do
you deserve it
you are worth so much mark no matter how
he's made you feel
and i'm telling you i think this is a
great fresh start for you you got the
cash you got the ira you're still going
to have a rental i'm telling you yeah
sell it
get debt free and start over you feel
that hope in his voice it all changed so
good george thank you pal good stuff
always good to be with you want to thank
our team in the control booth thank you
for what you all do to make this show
possible i want to thank our audience
we appreciate you so much we do this for
you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you